okay well good morning everyone and
thanks so much for spending your Tuesday
morning with me greetings from Stanford
I want to start out with a story it's
about a sergeant sergeant Edward Montoya
about ten years ago sergeant Montoya was
an Army medic stationed outside Mosul it
was right before Christmas and he was at
the mess digging into a piece of
cheesecake and all of a sudden on the
corner of his eyes he saw a flash the
boom of all booms it was a terrorist
lighting himself up and blowing up a
mess hall he ducked under the table and
was safe himself but when the the furor
ended and he came out and looked it was
carnage all around him all kinds of
people injured complexity what was he
going to do which person does he treat
who can be saved and that's really what
we're going to be talking about today is
the issue of complexity and so as you
can see sergeant Montoya is facing a
difficult challenge how to deal with the
complexity of war well maybe not the
same kind of personal stress lots of
people deal with complexity Janet Yellen
for example chairman of the Federal
Reserve deals in complexity
Mark Zuckerberg CEO of Facebook does as
well and we believe it or not even
crickets do it's not that easy to be a
cricket you've got a short life of a lot
to do the rest of us we deal with
complexity as well we've got too many
devices we've got to deal with the tax
code we can't understand our kids want
things our jobs want things we have too
much to do too much to cope with and
what what today's seminar is really
about is how do people cope with that
complexity the complexity of the federal
economy the complexity of face birth the
complexity of our own lives and the
argument today the basic argument is you
cope with complexity by being simple and
in particular simple rules
what are simple rules you can think of
simple rules as being rules of thumb or
heuristics they're cognitive shortcuts
they work because they save time and
effort
and they do it by focusing attention and
simplifying your thinking let me get a
little bit more specific about what I
mean the features of simple rules simple
rules are first of all simple there's
only maybe a handful two three four five
second thing as symbol rules are unique
simple rules depend on the person in the
situation your rules aren't necessarily
my rules
third simple rules relate to defined
activity it's not a platitude like being
nice to your mother on Mother's Day and
it's not settling world hunger either
it's much more precise and defined
activity let me give you an example of a
simple rules simple rules are simple
take the three food rules of Michael
Pollan Michael Pollan as many of you
know is a UC Berkeley professor and and
renowned food guru he's got three simple
rules for choosing what to eat number
one eat real food
it's food that your grandmother
recognizes second eat small portions
third eat mostly plants within those
three rules you can pick blueberries
kale or whatever I can choose something
else but we're following those three
simple rules second point those rules
depend on this person in the situation
so take the Stanford football team they
have rules for eating too but not the
same as Michael Pollan for example
football teams rules are eat breakfast
because they're students and they often
rushing to classes skip breakfast their
second rule is stay hydrated because
they're really active guys who need to
stay hydrated and their third rule is
you can eat anything you want as long as
you can pick it pluck it or kill it
notice there's some similarities is
Michael Pollan non-processed food but
after that no issues about portion
control like middle-aged Michael Pollan
and plenty of meat for guys who are
still building muscle and using them
let's take a corporate example
crowdfunding sites IndieGoGo vs.
Kickstarter and how they choose what
projects get on their sites ed IndieGoGo
anything goes as far as projects go
anything that's illegal that is so you
can fund your root canal or you can fund
your trip to Europe you can fund the
Jamaican bobsled team
you can fund your art project or your
business what products get featured or
what projects get featured on the
IndieGoGo site it's done strictly by an
algorithm popularity your project and
the effort that you put into promoting
your project let's contrast that with
Kickstarter also picking crowdfunding
projects but Kickstarter curates into 13
project categories and rejects about 25%
of the projects they're submitted how do
you get a featured project its staff
picks not an algorithm its staff takes
subjective versus objective the
IndieGoGo philosophy is the Internet is
about denier is for everyone the
Internet should be a place where
everybody deserves a rich uncle as long
as you put an effort you get to put your
project up there
in contrast Kickstarter is coming from a
philosophy of public funding for art and
curation what's the point
same basic business different rules
depending on the person in the situation
final point simple rules relate to a
defined activity again it's not about
solving healthcare it's about particular
activities like choosing what you're
going to have for lunch today or picking
crowdfunding projects so that's what
really the meaning of simple rules is
another thing I want to talk about it
this morning is the idea of types of
rules types of rules matter for a couple
reasons one is some of them are easy to
learn and some of them are hard to learn
and so obviously you have to work harder
to learn the ones that are hard to learn
hard to learn the second point and why
it's important to learn it is because
some roles are actually more important
for performance than other rules let's
take a look at some of the rules these
are the six types we're going to we're
going to explore a couple of the types
a common rule easy to learn rules what's
what we're calling a boundary rule
boundary rules cover situations like
yes/no decisions or situations where you
have too many alternatives so you have
lots of alternatives and you have to
choose a smaller number give you some
examples to bring it down into down from
hyperspace the weinstein company
weinstein company is one of the major
Hollywood movie companies has brought
you a lot of featured films that I'm
sure you've all seen pictured in the
slide is the imitation game for example
they also did silver linings playbook
and a number of other hit movies Chuck a
lot the artists and so on
keep process at Weinstein or one of the
key processes is picking movies you see
thousands of scripts in a year which
movies are you're actually gonna do well
it turns out the Weinstein Company has a
couple simple rules one of them is
always pick a flawed the sympathetic
main character in the case of the
imitation game it's alan turing a person
that i think most of us who would agree
as we're watching this flick he's a
really annoying guy even kind of a jerk
but yet you like him
he also has a basic human condition that
he's dealing with not just jerk them but
he's also he's also a gay at a time when
gays aren't respected and or even
tolerate or even legal so it's a flawed
but sympathetic main character basic
human condition silver linings playbook
if you remember that movie with Bradley
Cooper and Jennifer Lawrence it was
about dealing with mental illness
bradley cooper was was a a bipolar and
it was dealing with his he's coping with
that condition now does that mean that
wise how actually does every movie
actually have those two flawed pacific
main character basic human addition
actually no so weinstein would never
make a movie like gone girl what was
hard to like any characters or the
birdman again a movie that's hard to
like any characters you this much time
will also not do something like mission
impossible where's the basic human
condition there so the key point here is
there are lots of movies that could be
chosen they they focus on a few simple
ones a few simple rules to go through
that vast number of movie scripts to
pick out where something gonna be some
of the best ones another example give
you a smaller company called frontier
dental their problem is the sales
process the key issue for them
turns out they were calling on about a
hundred dentists a day each of their
sales people trying to sell a new
product around it was an innovative
tooth alignment system calling on about
a hundred people a day getting maybe two
or three dentists to to listen to them
and maybe by not very fun job of here
the salesperson
very profitable if your frontier gentle
and so the question is what do we do so
they started thinking about which
dentists have actually been listening
and how they're going to figure that out
one idea was maybe it's dentists or
between the ages of 35 and 50 you know
not old enough to maybe have an
established practice but not too older
they're not novel and innovative not to
offend those of you listeners who were
over 50 because as we all know there are
many 50 year olds who are innovative and
in fact those rules don't work those
rules didn't work because it didn't
actually capture who was innovative and
because it was really hard to figure out
for example how old the dentist was
instead I wanted to other rules that
were pretty easy to check and yet got
what they wanted first rule was always
go to a dentist who has a great website
that signals innovation second avoid any
dentist the Ted for finance charges in
the year check their credit report bad
credit reports don't go there
so by using those two rules great
websites good credit they got an
innovative dentists who paid their bills
and frontier dental had a major increase
not only in their sales but in their
profitability let me give you another
second kind of rule another kind of a
simple rule is the how to how to rule
again a common rule easy to learn this
one however is not about picking
alternatives rather it's about guiding
the basic steps of executing a task
important when innovation matters
believe it or not and also when future
situations are variable when you've got
a lot of situations to to fit into and
you can't just have a checklist that
fits everybody
give you an example Airbnb Airbnb is a
pretty interesting company as I think we
all know I think we were all but many of
us have probably tried Airbnb it turns
out for Airbnb that one of the key
activities is around helping hosts be
better hosts how do you do that what are
the rules when you're trying when you're
talking about hosts from San Francisco
to Bangladesh when you're talking about
hosting in the treehouse an apartment
luxury villa or just a plain everyday
house
one of the simple rules well first off
when the Airbnb was starting out and
started opening up new territories they
recruited hosts at parties at referral
parties you a current host bring
potential future hosts the idea here was
they this would help
Airbnb get the right kind of a host a
host that had slightly funky Airbnb vibe
not for example apartment managers who
were sort of more sterile instead people
who really cared about their space once
they have a cadre of house how do you
help host be good hosts couple simple
rules professional photographs of your
of your property so look at looking as
good as you can always ensuring that you
give your guests local tips on what's
going on at the farmers market what's
the best museum how to use the subway
whatever it is in your market it's about
local tips third tip always clean soap
clean soap is an immediate signal to a
guest that won't split this way if it's
not cleaned soap but somebody's been
already to washing with the soap it's an
immediate signal to the guest hmm maybe
this isn't the place I want to be so few
simple rules covering campsites two
castles one another company and another
common problem meetings we all spend
more time than we want to in a meeting
it was an issue of Twitter how do we
simplify our meetings how do we get rid
of this complexity the meetings how do
we how do we make them more efficient
couple key rules regardless in the
meeting no power points because they
take way too long to prepare waste of
time and also get people talking too
long and second one no cancelling if
we've got a meeting set up you've got to
show up people cancelling messes up
everybody's schedule no cancelling but
then that you can do what you want maybe
a third example will get a little
outside business and get a little little
edgier now that's white stripes
white stripes all of you may know some
of you may not but the white stripes did
an album in the early 2000s called white
blood cells major album of that decade
they wrote they did that album in ten
days ten days 18 songs what they were
doing was creating innovations in
amazing short amount of time how do they
do that
they have a couple simple rules no
covers meaning you can't play somebody
else's song no blues no guitar solos no
slide guitar no bass within that do what
you want and I think the subtle point
here is I know many of you in the tech
sector many many times we think
innovation is about having the rules
doing what you want to do in fact the
most innovative people from Claude Monet
to Jack White they have rules what
they're doing is not they're not outside
the box what they're doing is creating
their own box and within that box
creating great innovation another kind
of rule that I think you might find
interesting and I think is really
important now we're getting into harder
rules it turns out it's harder for
people to learn about things like
priority rules coordinating rules and
what we're going to focus on here timing
rules yet timing rules are one of those
kinds of rules that's harder to learn
bigger payback what are the timing rule
fits it fits in situations who you want
to specify one to act rhythms sequences
of activities maybe deadlines they're
pretty useful when you need to get
things done in timing matters you're
also pretty useful when you want to get
started get going let me give you a
couple of examples one of this Pixar
Pixar as you may know started out the
first movie woods Toy Story Toy Story
was a huge hit joy story's still a huge
hit but Toy Story had a problem
it took Pixar for years to develop Toy
Story it's pretty tough to have a viable
business if you only get a movie out
every four years it also is pretty hard
to attract talented people to
if it takes you 40 years to see what
happens with your work so what Pixar
executives did what has actually started
to go into a timing rule and that timing
rule was one movie a year let's do one
movie a year it was actually not that
easy to implement because what that took
is actually building a pipeline of a
year of a movie that's about to release
in the next year to two years three
years four years you actually had to
have a pipeline of four movies to do
that but do you go from step to step to
step for what so it took six are a
couple years to do this but they
eventually ended up with essentially one
movie a year whether it was ratatouille
Finding Nemo up whatever they also put
in a second timing rule which was every
for every once a year a movie and
released that movie at Thanksgiving
which is the major which is the start of
one of the major movie going seasons for
families in the year so once a year
release of Thanksgiving once a year
release of Thanksgiving since that time
they've switched up the rule every a
little bit and sometimes they will
release into someone and every so often
they have a hiccup for example a year
where they just don't feel that the
movie lives up to Pixar standards but
otherwise they stick to the rhythm
another example baby one you don't know
this is a company called cream quest
dream quest is in a somewhat unglamorous
business of concrete but while concrete
may be unglamorous concrete it turns out
is important after water it's the
highest per capita income consumption
good in the world and I was also a major
polluter it is the third largest source
of manmade carbon dioxide pollution
rehnquist executives and scientists
started studying how to make concrete
better and acting went back to the
ancient Egyptians who are the
originators of concrete
the ancient Egyptians whipped up their
concrete using blood and horsehair to
make it better
perfect Wes decided they maybe didn't
want to use blood and horsehair but they
were going to use a few modern
equivalents of that and came up with an
innovative concrete that had that had
the energy consumption with less
cracking these meanings you needed to
use less and
less use because it was stronger so an
eco win-win they took this concrete
tried to sell it and in particular took
it to Las Vegas to a convention of
people who are interested in concrete I
have to admit I wasn't there I had about
had a lot of interest because it was a
great product had over a hundred people
who wanted to be these sellers of this
concrete the problem for prim course is
how do you pick which which hundred
which which five which to who they have
a couple of rules but what but two of
them were time intervals like one of
them I'm gonna focus on one of them and
that was we're a small company we can
only add a new partner every month every
three months and so they got into a
rhythm of every three months a new
partner every two months a new partner
we try to do it every month we just
don't have the capacity if it's too long
than that we lose the momentum of our
product so very simple timing rule every
three months we got a partner so that
kind of rule that I think is also pretty
interesting rules is what's known as a
stopping rule stopping rules it turns
out is the hardest rule to learn yet
what are the most important when to call
it quits in other words when do we stay
when do we go first of all I actually
talked a little bit about pretty quick
before I go and switch over to Steve
Blank
but prim quest the concrete company we
just talked about they also had a
stopping rule for their partners that
rule was if a partner does not adopt a
product within three months we dropped
that partner so in other words if we set
up a partner they don't develop they
don't do anything with our concrete for
three months time to stop time to move
on to a new partner another another
stopping rule is offered by my colleague
Steve Blank Steve like you may recognize
some of you as the author of lean
launchpad well known innovator in may in
the Entrepreneurship space many of you
may know his rule about get out of the
building talk to a hundred customers
you may also even know his building make
sure those conversations are face to
face but what I want to focus on is his
stopping rule when do you decide that
your business isn't going to work you
need to pivot and he's got a very simple
stopping rule
you have to answer four questions does
the customer see the problem if the
customer sees a problem will they pay to
solve it second kind of question third
questions if the customer wolf will buy
a product will the press or buy it from
you and the fourth question is can you
make the product if you answer no to any
one of those four questions it's time to
stop that business pivot and move on to
your next stop next crack of the
business model finally before I go on to
the next part just just don't worry
about crickets I started about crickets
at the very beginning you probably
wondering what what are crickets doing
in the story but there's too much on
crickets because after all this is a
business presentation but but let me
just say that turns out animals use a
lot of simple rules because after all
animals aren't all that smart they don't
have a lot of time and so you have to
keep it simple for an animal crickets
have a great mating stopping rules that
you might recognize how does news
cricket understand I've found mr.
cricket who's mr. right turns out she
uses a stopping rule she picks mr. right
if he can chirp three times a second or
more but if she can't find mr. right in
24 hours times women she's got to move
on she just takes the next available
some of you may recognize that as also
bar behavior it's also known as the
variables variable stopping rule with
the threshold overall what's the point
here stopping rules people forget
stopping rules they're super important
in fact they could be the most important
type of rule finally to wrap it up let's
just talk a little bit about how do you
create simple rules you determine an
objective keep it specific what do you
want more or less else find the bottom
line what's keeping you from really
creating that objective then crafting
rules from expert advice maybe from your
friends and colleagues tracking your own
experience let me give you an example
google googas objectives has very often
been growths what's stopping their
growth what's the bottleneck
there are a couple bottlenecks but
probably the biggest bottleneck at least
historically has been how do we find
enough great computer scientists to
develop our products so it's actually a
hiring bottleneck how do you find great
computer scientists obviously you can
check good schools obvious you can check
for grades but after that how do you
tell a great computer scientist turns
out Google has a couple simple rules
which they developed from tracking their
own behavior and success from best
practice and from just talking Google
favors people who are also not just top
computer scientists from a transcript
point of view but who are slightly
eccentric because they're typically more
creative Google wants computer
scientists who never fudge on their
resume because integrity is huge and
Google likes computer scientists who are
referred by other Googlers because after
all other Googlers are some of the best
the best people at spotting the kind of
people that would work at Google our
premises are president prim Chris just
so we use them again our concrete people
once again their growth is there their
bottleneck was growth and profits their
excuse me their objective is growth and
profit their bottleneck was partnering
their simple rules I told you those
before three months otherwise we stop
every two months we add somebody they
also had an interesting rule around pick
partners who have a screen machine you
and I probably don't know what a screen
machine is but in the concrete world
that signals innovative high quality
manufacturers and partners
overall what's the point simple rules
add value I think in your life because
they make your decision-making faster
because they give you more flexibility
in what you do think Weinstein lots of
different kinds of movies and they give
you better coordination so in summary if
you're sitting if you're sitting at your
office today and you've got too many
devices and too much to do and too many
meetings to go to and you're worrying
about your kids and you can't keep track
of what's going on in your email maybe
it's time for simple rules hopefully
this webinar will help you think about
that and they in a way that maybe give
you some peace of mind and a whole lot
more simplicity and maybe a quote one of
my favorite simple rules guys Leonardo
da Vinci simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication
so when complexity has you down try
simple rules thanks a lot for listening
so I think let's let's start we've got a
number of questions from the audience so
let's start with the first one that asks
how would you recommend to start
creating personal simpler rules rather
than business simple rules
okay well great question how do i how to
create personal rules I think the first
thing to think about is is really think
about your life and what is it you want
more of for example more family time
more travel time more me time what do
you want less of less hassle less
commuting less whatever so thinking what
is your J so the first thing is why is
your objective for example do you want
but say it's better help the second
thing is what's the bottom line what's
really keeping you from better health
join your kids more whatever it is that
you want let's say it's better health
well you've just that's actually
probably one of the trickiest parts of
is what what is keep you from better
health for example is it is it is it
exercisers a diet so I so I had a friend
for example for whom she thought about
exercise she thought about diet and then
realized we know it's really um you know
exercise I'm doing enough exercise now I
don't really have time given my work
schedule to can do more exercise it's
really got to be diet then what this
person did was started tracking her diet
choices for example what was she eating
every day did that for a couple of days
realize that her bottleneck her problem
which is now we're focusing on what's
really keeping her from health was was
she was pretty good during the day but
once it was after dinner she was having
that extra glass of wine or she was
having that Ben & Jerry's she was
snacking after after dinner and so that
became she started focusing in on that
she also asked for some friends or some
tips she got a couple of diet books and
came up with a couple of simple rules
about snacking after dinner first of all
since she couldn't completely eliminate
them she said alright no snacking during
the week but I can do it on the weekends
so weekends are okay second one was I'm
never gonna snack out of a bag my snacks
were always in a bowl she had a couple
other rules a basic just just two or
three rules and so at the end of a hard
day a tired day when she's things have
been hectic when whatever has been going
on has been going on and her resistance
is down she just relied on this couple
simple rules and actually lost 15 pounds
pretty fast so what's the idea it's
really the same idea as for businesses
what's the objectives that you're really
trying to achieve
what are the bottlenecks they're really
keeping you from that your exercise is a
diet
whatever and then what is a couple of
rules two three four five they're
keeping you from getting there and again
use ideas from your friends read books
or just track your own behavior so
another question that came up here is
how do you understand what is that
bottleneck it seems like a pretty
crucial element in the process and what
are some techniques that you can share
about how to understand what the
bottleneck is and address it
yeah the bottleneck is actually really
really crucial and as it was in the
health example it wasn't clear what it
was in a sales example it's often not
clear you know is we all have sales
because poor sales people bad products
good competitors whatever it takes them
you have to think about that for a while
what we've seen successful in businesses
is getting together people perhaps
several sets of people from different
parts of the organization or different
levels so for example a team of people
at high levels and middle levels and low
levels to brainstorm what the bottleneck
can be and to try to not just see what
the superfast bottleneck may be but
maybe the underlying cause so for
example in the case of Google the
problem was inability to develop certain
kinds of apps but the real underlying
problem is with lack of a computer
scientists and actually Yahoo is facing
that same problem these days how do they
get mobile apps it's not the problem is
not mobile apps the problem is actually
computer scientists so trying to so to
summarize that two strategies for
getting at bottlenecks one is several
different teams within your in here your
organization brainstorming about it and
just trying to come up with ideas and
then thinking this through second idea
is to go beyond the surface and try to
think of the cause behind the
superficial manifestation so what's the
underlying root cause causality and and
focus in on that you can tell by the way
if you've got the wrong bottleneck is if
you try and change the rules around that
bottleneck and nothing happens it
doesn't really improve you're probably
on the wrong bottleneck
great thank you one other question that
has to do maybe with with the wrong
rules being created is what happens if
you define a simple rule and the rule
isn't working or how do you know that
it's not the right simple rule and how
do you pivot or change that those rules
what are some examples you can give of
that okay so you what about the wrong
rules well first of all the good news is
that there are a lot of situations when
just having a rule is better than no
rule so you don't have to have the
perfect rule and oftentimes as you start
out and it may not be a good rule so
first point is don't stress about
getting the absolute optimal rule just
get a rule and you usually would be
better off second thing is how do you
know well maybe you didn't actually end
up with with rules or not working you
can you can figure that out by if
whatever it is you're trying to achieve
is not again not getting better
so you you've changed your your your
rules for sales pre-fills calling
patterns and you aren't getting more
sales that's suggesting that those rules
aren't working you've either got the bar
wrong bottleneck you've got the wrong
rules so you look so the way you tell
the rules really are not working is
you're not achieving the objective
whether it's a more innovative product
whether it's more sales whether it's
better movies whether it's hiring more
computer scientists if you're not
getting the action that you wanted
that's telling you that either the rules
at the bottleneck aren't right
third when you've got the wrong rules
what do you do you go back to the
process and in particular track your own
behavior
so for example if it's if it's you're
failing to get the right computer
scientists track what's wrong what
what's what what are you doing when
you're getting it right what are you
doing when you're getting it wrong track
your own rules the other thing you can
do is also ask ask professional
colleagues what do they do they might
give you some ideas they might be able
to critique you for example you're
trying to hire and people don't want to
work for you well if you really ask your
friends what's wrong with my company
they may be able to say you know people
don't like this about your company or
it's bad about your company gives you
some insight so track your behavior ask
some friends maybe check some expert
sources
all right so we have a number of
questions around how do you make sure
you stick to the rule some people are
commenting that you know what if you're
more of a free spirit or if you have
more free-spirited culture in your
company or how do you know how do you
just make sure that you you stick to the
rules that you set for yourselves and
what are some some ways to address that
okay well I can I can relate to to not
wanting to stick to the rules good
because you know that's why that's why I
like living on the west coast you don't
have not so many rules but certainly
certainly if you take somebody like Jack
White and the White Stripes they aren't
exactly your Boy Scout rule followers
but yet I think what what's important to
realize is that people are more
innovative when they have a couple of
rules whether it's I do whether it's the
White Stripes wherever a few rules
define the box and define define where
creativity will come from so first point
is is to recognize the innovation comes
from I'm not a thousand rules but a
couple of rules is actually where
innovation comes from because you get
some degree of leverage on your time in
fact when we first did the research
around this these these ideas we saw
that that that certain parts of the
country had lots of rules and it was
bureaucracy but the West Coast problem
was not enough rules too much craziness
second night a second thing that you
were mentioned if I was asked was about
well how do you stick to the rules I'm
not really a rule following kind of girl
or guy what do you do here I think is
first of all is keeping number small
keep it down if you have trouble if you
don't if you're not a rural person try
to rules maybe even one rule you'll get
you may get a lot of results just even
on one or two rules five rules may be
too much for you it may just be two
rules or even one will be able to do it
and it's easier to follow two rules both
because if you're a free spirit it's
easier it's also easier if you if you're
tired if you're stressed out and so on
it's people particularly value
particularly do well with with a few
rules in just those situations where
things are hectic when they're stressed
out when they're hassled they when they
when their mental reservoir is low one
or two things that's all I can remember
that's the perfect number
great so one more question I think and
then we'll we'll be ready to wrap it up
so there we have a question around what
if you manage a diverse team with lots
of different types of personalities how
do you make sure that the rules that you
set are a good fit for all these
different personalities and and
behavioral styles
yeah I'd say simple will directly really
good for that because simple rules are
simple which usually accommodate lots of
personality styles I what I've seen is
one of the effective ways of doing this
is actually meet with your team in fact
Mary Mary Barra this is a bit high level
perhaps but Mary Barra the CEO of
General Motors was looking into General
Motors dress code and she realized that
the dress code had proliferated into
into several pages of what to wear it
would cover people on the line people in
the office people who were in R&D people
and one other people who are test track
drivers and then all these rules for all
these different kinds of people what to
wear and if someone symbolically but
also somewhat pragmatically she said
let's forget it we're going to one rule
dress appropriately and we figured that
GM employees are big boys and big girls
they know what dress appropriately means
and so she went down to dress
appropriately she got some feedback over
from a middle manager who said you know
dress appropriately is great but you
know sometimes my people show up at a
client meeting and they think it's
casual Friday but it's not and so what
she said back to that person was
understand what you need to do is go
back to your team and explain why dress
appropriate is important and what dress
appropriate means in different settings
so one of those employees end up doing
still doing their own thing on clothes
but for those who are paid maybe a
little more on the casual side they had
an outfit at the office that if there
was going to be a client meeting they
dressed up for it and then dressed down
but they understood what they had a
better understanding of what dress
appropriate meant so hopefully that
gives you some insight into how to let
let a simple rule work for many sizes
wonderful so I think this has been
really informative I want to thank
professor Eisenhart again for spending
this time with her and sharing some of
the insights from her extensive research
and her book on the topic of simple
rules
I invite you again to learn more about
our offering the innovation
entrepreneurship certificate at our
website create stanford.edu and to
enroll in our next webinar on July 16th
on negotiations and how to get more of
what you want so with that I want to
wish you a good rest of the day and hope
to see you at our next webinar